Narrator:
Tonight, on "Shark Tank"...
The average American
is swimming in debt
and is just trying to keep up
with the cost of living.
I'm not an engineer, but I am
a creative technologist.
[ Laughing ] What?
What would that do?
You shouldn't be overly
concerned with debt.
You're a profitable company.
The way I look at it ‐‐
I haven't finished, Kevin.
He's trying to gouge you.
Can you come back to me?
No gouging.
It's a reasonable offer.
There's nobody here that
can market better than me.
Oh, that's ‐‐
[ Laughs ]
You can laugh
all you want.
I'm laughing.
You should have been
much nicer to me.
You wouldn't have
this dilemma.
He hates that.
I don't even like Kevin.
Oh, wow!
♪♪
Narrator:
First into the Tank is a stylish
trend in accommodation.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Brett Ellenson,
and I'm from Tempe, Arizona.
And my name is David Sodemann,
and I'm from Phoenix, Arizona.
Our company
is Boho Camper Vans.
We are seeking
a $300,000 investment
in exchange for 10%.
Boho Camper Vans
is changing the way
that people travel and live
through one simple,
yet powerful word ‐‐
"freedom."
We hear the word
"freedom" all the time,
but most of us never get
to truly experience it.
The average American
is swimming in debt,
tied to an inflexible
work schedule,
and is just trying to keep up
with the cost of living.
Most of us feel as though
we'll never catch up,
and there must be a better way
to experience life.
Boho Camper Vans is giving
people back that freedom.
We rent
and we sell them.
So, whether you're looking
for the tiny home on wheels
for your
short‐term adventure
or the ability to live
on the road full time,
Boho Camper Vans has
everything you need ‐‐
comfortable beds,
kitchenettes with running water,
solar‐powered electricity,
pull‐out countertops, and more.
The best part ‐‐ you
can take them anywhere.
Mobile living
is not a new concept,
but Boho Vans
is different
because we cater
to a broader demographic.
Our vans are affordable,
easy to drive,
and ‐‐ let's be honest ‐‐
extremely photogenic.
"Shark Tank."    "Shark Tank."
[ Laughter ]
Let's help people
live more with less.
Who wants to join
this movement?
But first...
Oza: Let's try it.
...who wants to check out
this van?
‐I do.
‐Yeah!
Lock us all in there.
[ Both laugh ]
Greiner: This looks, like,
totally fun.
Yeah.
Sodemann: We try to make it
look like a tiny home.
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
I kind of love it,
right?
If it had a shower...
Yeah.
Greiner: If it had a shower.
Running water?
‐Yes.
‐Yeah?
You could actually
hit the switch
right under the countertop
right there.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There you go.
Oh, okay.
Sink works.
Yep.
And what's it take
to do a shower?
They're out the back.
We can show it to you.
O'Leary:
There's a shower back there.
Greiner: I got to look.
Don't see that too often.
Yep.
We got the shower here.
Sodemann:
But here's something that you're
actually really gonna love.
Oh, you're kidding!
So, we actually do
butcher‐block countertops.
This comes out about
another 3 feet,
and you can do all
your cooking under here.
Oh, my God.
How fun is this?
Extra storage.
It's really cool.
Thank you.
What's your background?
How'd you get into this?
Sodemann:
The idea came from a trip.
So, I went with my girlfriend
to Maui,
and we explored the island
in a camper van.
So, we came back and realized no
one was doing this in Phoenix,
and it's such
a hot tourism town,
and everybody rents
their cars
and they go
to the Grand Canyon,
and lodging up there
is suspect.
So I called Brett,
'cause I know he's
a really great builder.
He's a master
at his craft.
So, we discussed it
over one night,
and the next couple days,
we bought a van and got to work.
My background is machining
and fabrication.
I've been doing
tool and die work
since I've been
14 years old.
What's your background?
My background ‐‐
I went to school for
design and marketing.
We started this
as a passion.
We wanted to just use it,
you know,
and maybe make a little money
on the side
if we weren't using it,
and then we
couldn't even use it
because it was booked up
so much.
Wow.
So we built another one ‐‐
and another one.
So you have
a whole bunch of them?
We have five vans
in our rental fleet.
Greiner: Five vans.
And we've sold 12.
And you've sold 12?
How much would you
rent this out for?
It comes out to be
just under $200 a night,
and we have
a three‐night minimum.
Ellenson: Yeah.
Oh!
And once you buy it
and trick it out,
how much are you
into the van for?
For our rental vans,
we're into them
right at about $20,000.
That's it, huh? All‐in?
That's not bad.
Sodemann: Yeah.
Wow.
Because we're buying the vans,
we're sourcing them used.
On a $20,000 van,
how much revenue
can you generate in a year?
So, we're doing about
$2,000 a month per van.
Would you say you pay back
a van within a year?
Eight months.
How many have you guys sold
for people to live in?
Literally, to live in?
So, out of the 12 vans
that we've sold,
it's basically
half of them.
Really?
We see this as
mobile real estate.
We see this as kind of
the next level of living.
Oza: What gives you guys
an edge and a difference,
and how do you scale this model
beyond a master craftsman?
So, first off, they're
very affordable in this space.
We have lots and lots
and lots of people
that have reached out
to us,
just wanting to get
on our list to build a van.
Tell me what fitting it out
like that costs.
This van was $15,000 used.
Mm‐hmm.
And we charge $29,000
for this build‐out.
And I'm curious.
How long does it take you
to actually do that van?
So, right now,
we have our process
just under three weeks.
And do you have any debt?
Nope.
Zero.
No debt?
Good for you.
So, how much did you make
in the last year?
So, in the last eight months,
in 2019,
we're at $195,500 net.
Wow! Good for you.
Net or sales?
Our sales total, this year,
calendar year ‐‐ $493,000.
Greiner: Wow.
And $195,000 net?
‐Wow!
‐Really?
That's really impressive.
Good for you guys.
That's impressive.
So, you're looking
for money from us.
Ellenson: Yes.
What are you gonna do
with that money?
So, I'm gonna take the money,
and I'm gonna put it
into manufacturing and get it
so we can actually have
finished pieces ready
to go in the van,
and we can hire on
just installers,
'cause everything's
pre‐cut, pre‐fab.
So, it's like pre‐fab?
Exactly.
Gotcha.
Let's go to the numbers,
'cause I'm a numbers guy.
So, if I'm an investor,
what am I going to make
next year?
So, this year,
we're gonna project
to be at $800,000
in sales...
Okay.
...by the end
of the year.
So, next year,
we're projecting 1.9.
1.9?
Cuban: Oh, so, you guys
will kill it.
That's what we project
next year.
What am I gonna make on that,
pre‐tax?
I think we're gonna be
close to a million.
A million?
Ellenson: Yeah.
Cuban: [ Clapping ]
Out of 1.9?
You're gonna net a million?
Sodemann: Just based
on our margins now.
Yep.
Why don't you have
a lot of competitors?
I don't get that.
We talk about it a lot.
It's time, it's space,
it's know‐how.
Alright, so, I'm in.
For how much?
Hold your horses,
Barbara.
[ Chuckles ]
This is "Shark Tank."
I love your numbers,
but you're only doing 495.
Let's round it up ‐‐
500 or 1,000.
And you are basically asking
for a valuation of $3 million.
That's a sporty valuation.
Yes.
Cuban:
Not if they're making a million
in profit next year.
Well, wait a second. That
assumes everything goes right.
Guys,
I'll make it simpler.
Look, I think it's
a great business for y'all,
but it's just not a fit
for me right now.
Congratulations, man,
but I'm out.
The way I see it ‐‐
The way I look at it and say ‐‐
Oza: I haven't finished,
Kevin.
Oh, sorry.
Go ahead.
Yeah, really.
Give me a moment,
because, you know ‐‐
You don't get a moment.
My juices are flowing.
I look at it
and say to myself,
"I should be the third partner
at 33 1/3%."
I'll give you the $300,000.
I want 1/3 of the business,
because I'm Mr. Wonderful.
They don't look happy,
Kevin.
They look very happy.
[ Laughter ]
You should always be happy
when you get an offer
from Mr. Wonderful.
Oza:
So, look, he's trying to gouge
you. Can you come back to me?
'Cause I was putting
some real numbers on there.
O'Leary: No gouging.
It's a reasonable offer.
Thank you for the offer.
Yeah, we appreciate it.
[ Laughter ]
Oza: "Thank you for the offer,
but piss off."
Greiner:
"Thank you for the offer."
O'Leary:
Well, let's see ‐‐‐
So, what are you
gonna do, Rohan?
Oza: Look, you got to get
to a more reasonable
and fair valuation
on this.
1/3 is too much.
I would go
for the $300,000.
Happy to bring all of
the sort of marketing muscle
and awareness building
that this thing needs to have,
but I'd want 25%.
Whoa!
What's the difference?
You get Mr. Wonderful ‐‐
I mean, I'm a quarter.
There are three quarters.
It's a big delta.
If you guys are interested,
let's talk about it.
If not,
I'm fine to move out.
You guys got to pick it
or leave it.
You haven't
heard from me yet.
And who was most excited?
You were very thrilled.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Narrator:
One Shark is out.
David and Brett have
two offers on the table
for their designer van
business, Boho.
But Lori also seems interested.
Greiner:
I think it's super cool.
I could see people
loving this.
Um...I got to think
for a minute.
I'm going to think for a minute
about my offer.
Well, while she thinks,
return to me for a minute.
Oza: If you guys
want feedback, great.
If not,
I'm happy to be out.
No, they want more offers,
and here comes an offer.
I don't think you need
a partner at all.
I think you need cash.
That's it.
You've got a plan.
You're working the plan.
It's going exactly as you had
wished it would ‐‐
probably better ‐‐ and I
do believe your projections,
that you're gonna make
$1 million next year, okay?
So, I'll give you
exactly what you want ‐‐
$300,000 for 10% ‐‐
but I'll give it to you
in the form
of $150,000 in cash up front
and $150,000 in credit line,
and then
if the business expands
and continues to grow
at the same rate ‐‐
and I see no reason
why not ‐‐
I'll continue
to fund the growth.
Simple.
Interesting.
Oza:
How is that a Sharky offer?
You're giving them
exactly what they wanted.
No, it's not exactly
what they offered.
It's half
If you're considering
debt,
I'm far more creative
than Barbara is,
and I can make you
an offer
you might find
extremely attractive.
And you still get the Sharks
that way.
How about I loan you
the $300,000
at 9% for two years,
venture debt,
and I get 7% equity?
You could walk into a bank
and get it for less.
It's a terrible offer.
Yeah.
Respectfully, we really pride
ourself on being debt‐free.
So you don't want
to do that.
Good for you.
You were listening to Barbara
with her debt deal.
Well, let me make you
an offer.
What?!
I'll do the $300,000
at 20%,
but mine has a caveat.
I want a charitable component
in this.
To a van?
For what?
Hear me out.
To a homeless cause.
Yeah, I hear you.
O'Leary:
Give it to a charity.
There's a lot of homeless people
in America.
Absolutely.
I see it constantly
because I'm always
in just major cities.
We absolutely love
that idea.
It's something we've
been wanting to align
with ‐‐ a social cause.
We love it.
Respectfully, would you
be able to go down
to 15%
with that same offer?
You know, that 15%
is really low.
Does that mean you're not
considering my offer?
Nor my offer?
I would stick it
at the 20%.
You know, guys, my offer
is really the best offer here
'cause it gives you
exactly what you need.
And in addition to that,
there's nobody here
that can market better than me.
Oh, that's ‐‐
[ Laughs ]
There is no one here
that ‐‐
You can laugh
all you want.
I'm laughing.
There's no one here ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
I'm totally laughing.
You shouldn't be
overly concerned with debt.
You're a profitable company.
Take the debt issue
off the table.
I respect
your whole debt‐free strategy,
but I wouldn't be concerned
with these guys.
They're not gouging you
at 20% interest rate.
Thank you for
the business advice.
So, I'm the lowest‐cost deal,
if you actually think about it,
by miles.
$300,000 debt at 9%
for two years, 24 months,
and I only want 7% equity.
What was the interest on
the loan that you're offering?
Whatever interest I get
on the loan, I pass on to you.
It's not to make money.
It's so that you take off the
table the least amount of stock,
because I've been
in the position
of almost selling
a lot of stock
and a few years later
realizing ‐‐
Mine's the least stock,
Barbara.
...realizing that I'd made
a terrible mistake
if I had done the deal.
Why give up 10
when you can give up 7?
Hold on.
And I'm a sweetheart.
Just give up 7.
We can give up...
Oza: Can I do
a drumroll, please?
...then we're only having to
pay back the other 150.
[ Both talking indistinctly ]
[ Whispering ]
Barbara?
[ Whispering ] Yeah.
Yeah, let's do it.
Barbara?
You got a deal.
You got it, baby.
Cuban: Nice!
[ Laughs ]
Kevin got smoked
by Barbara!
Yay, Barb!
Smoked!
Nice one, Barbara.
‐Nice!
‐Thank you.
Sodemann:
Thank you so much.
We're so excited.
Thank you very much.
Good luck, guys.
Congratulations.
Good luck.
Sodemann: Thank you.
Oh, man!
Ellenson: So, Barbara was
a perfect fit for us
'cause she knew we
didn't want any debt,
and she gave us a way
to pay it off quickly.
And Barbara, she knows
real estate, so...
Totally.
...we keep touting we're
mobile real estate,
Yeah.
we're the future of it,
so we're glad
to have her on board 'cause
she's gonna take us places.
Yep.
♪♪
Narrator: In Season 6,
David Heath and Randy Goldberg
struck a deal
with Daymond John for Bombas,
their sock company
with a social mission.
You have a deal.
We'll take the deal.
Mazel!
Narrator:
Let's see how they're doing now.
Heath: Six years ago,
we quit our jobs
to start a sock company.
We wanted to have
an impact in the community
by donating a pair of socks
for every pair sold,
but we had no idea
that it would turn into
the movement
that it is today.
We've done over $225 million
in revenue
and donated over
30 million pairs of socks
to those in need.
For years, our customers
have been asking for more,
so a few months ago,
Bombas launched
the most comfortable
T‐shirt ever.
Just like our socks,
for every T‐shirt we sell,
we're gonna donate one
to the homeless community.
We have been giving socks
to the Bowery Mission
since we started this company,
and we couldn't be more excited
to have our T‐shirt
donation event with them.
What size would you like?
Medium.
Medium?
Goldberg: The Bombas
donation T‐shirt is built
to meet the needs of people who
are experiencing homelessness.
It's extra durable,
it has reinforced seams
and an anti‐microbial treatment
so it stays fresh longer
between washes.
John: Man, you don't need
an extra large.
You need a large
like me, man.
You're the same size
as me, brother.
John: It's absolutely amazing
to be here in the community
and seeing the people
one‐on‐one
and pressing the palms to them
and talking to them.
John: How you doing, man?
Man: Hey!
What's happening?
How you doing?
This is not about
checkbook philanthropy.
This is rolling up your sleeves
and being able to meet the ones
that you are serving.
Nice to meet you.
Heath:
It's always so inspiring
to keep doing events like this,
giving back
to the community,
as it reminds us
why we do what we do.
You always make it good
when you come.
You always make it good.
John: This has been such
a unique investment for me.
I've learned so much
about a social cause.
I've learned about giving
to a community
and making sure
that it's infectious
for other people
who want to give, as well.
It is absolutely amazing,
and I'm proud to be part of it.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next into the Tank is a unique
offering in the snack space.
♪♪
Hi.
My name is Nadine Habayeb.
I live in Boston, Massachusetts,
and I'm here seeking $200,000
for 10% of our company, Bohana.
Sharks, like many Americans,
popcorn was one
of my favorite snacks ‐‐
until I discovered
something better.
I'd like to introduce you
to Bohana,
a delicious and nutritious snack
made out of
popped water lily seeds.
You heard me right ‐‐
seeds of a water lily plant.
Not those small lily pads
that you see floating on ponds
here in the U. S.,
but a giant variety that are
native to the north of India.
These plants produce seeds,
and when roasted over high heat,
they pop
right out of their shell ‐‐
just like popcorn, but better,
because popped water lily seeds
contain 50% more protein,
fewer calories and fat,
and my favorite part ‐‐
no kernel,
so nothing to get stuck
in your teeth.
Damn.
Wow.
When my co‐founder, Priyal,
introduced me
to these beautiful seeds,
I quickly said goodbye
to popcorn
and hello
to my new favorite snack.
Now, Priyal
can't be with us today
because she, too,
is about to pop.
[ Laughter ]
Priyal grew up in India,
where they've been eating
water lily seeds for centuries,
and today,
they're one of the world's
fastest‐growing ingredients.
And I can't wait
for you to try some.
So, who wants to get in on this
wildly fast‐moving food trend
and help bring Bohana
to snackers all across America?
Me.
Dying to try.
Let's try some.
Yes. Please do.
Tell us what we're trying here.
Tell us what we're trying.
Habayeb:
So, on my right, your left,
you have
our Himalayan pink salt.
I like starting with this one
because it's a great way
to taste the intrinsic flavor
of the seed itself.
The middle one
is our white cheddar.
This is
our most popular flavor,
and it's
our only non‐vegan flavor.
Wow. That's pretty good.
And our Soulful Spice
is the bright‐red one,
which has a little bit
of a kick to it.
It's very similar
to puffed rice.
Yes. Yes.
To me.
I mean, in taste.
It's lighter than popcorn,
tastier than popcorn...
It's very good.
...and airy as could be.
It's delicious.
The question is,
is the taste profile there?
Would you trade this
for popcorn?
I would.
So, there is a bit
of an intrinsic taste.
You know,
it's a water seed.
It has a smokiness that's quite
natural to the seed itself.
They have all nine
essential amino acids,
and that's very rare to find
in a plant‐based food,
is really what
makes this very special.
Do I have to worry about
a huge educational process
with the snacking public?
Yes. We know this is something
that we are pioneering.
We are the first people
to be bringing water lily seeds
to the U. S.
The "Aha" moment
is when people try this product.
Every single demo
that we've done
in stores that we sell in,
we've completely sold out
of every single bag
that we sell in‐store.
Really?
But they don't even know
what this is, right?
But when they taste it, they're
willing to make that change.
So, the familiarity
and similarity to popcorn
is what's really helpful
for someone.
So, what do you
sell these for?
Is this the same price
as a popcorn bag?
Habayeb: It's more expensive
than popcorn.
By how much?
So, it's...
Twice the price.
...almost twice as much.
It's $3.99
for a bag of ‐‐
Whoa!
$3.99 this bag?
Nadine, that's
a lot of money.
But this is
actually the same price
as all the other snacks
on the shelf that it lives with.
So, you will not actually
find this on a shelf
where you see popcorn
or potato chips.
You're gonna see this where you
find your better‐for‐you,
alternative‐ingredient snacks,
not processed, not extruded.
What does "extrude" mean?
Extruded is when you
reconstitute a flour
into the shape of a ‐‐
O'Leary:
What I like about you ‐‐
we're hitting you hard,
and you keep coming back.
She's got the answers.
You know your stuff,
Nadine.
I'm the person who buys
all of the snack things
that are, like, high protein
and low fat and low sodium.
So, when I look at this,
the only thing that's missing
for me here is fiber.
Habayeb: Sure.
Can you add fiber to it?
Have you been thinking
of adding fiber to it?
Totally.
So, one of the really
interesting things
about the seed itself ‐‐ when
you grind that down to a flour,
it does extrude, so we can play
with the nutrient density,
we can combine higher protein,
higher fiber.
Nadine, tell us a little
bit more about yourself.
Sure, sure.
You're pretty impressive,
standing in your space there.
I have a background
in marketing.
I used to work
in the fashion industry.
I worked for
a French fashion house.
Which one?
Yves Saint Laurent.
Ooh‐la‐la!
I love that.
I was actually living
in the Middle East.
Which city?
I lived in Dubai. I was
actually born and raised there.
So, I'm originally Lebanese.
My father
was based in the U.A.E.
and in some Gulf countries
for his work,
and so I was born there,
and that's where I grew up,
kind of moving in and out,
and I lived in the U. S.
only when I went to school,
actually, for my undergrad,
and then later, my master's.
So, you're at the fashion house,
and you were...
Yeah, so, then I went back
to do my MBA,
and so ‐‐
Where?
I ended up finishing
at Babson College.
We launched
in April in 2019 ‐‐
'18. Excuse me.
This is
your first full year?
Yes.
So, what have you done
in your first full year?
'Cause you're
asking for ‐‐
Yeah.
...before Kevin gets to it,
might as well beat him to it ‐‐
a $2 million valuation.
Yes.
We've done a revenue
of $123,000.
Over what period of time?
Over the past 16 months.
Okay.
We've been in retail
for only about nine months,
since the beginning
of this year.
We spent the first phase really
testing out our market online,
on Amazon and our website,
some specialty ‐‐
Nadine, it's
a lot more expensive,
and it has kind of a unique
taste that you have to adapt to,
but it's a slog, right?
It's not a straight path,
and it's very difficult.
While the product
was good,
it's gonna take
some getting used to.
I just don't get excited
enough about it,
so for those reasons,
I'm out.
I'll make you an offer.
Just like that, Barbara?
Yeah.
I've been listening hard.
This girl's hot.
She's very good,
but there's only one
Lebanese‐Irish guy here.
This is what I like
about the product ‐‐
I love the fact that
it's more digestible.
No choking aspect,
I like.
It's more filling
than popcorn.
I've been sitting here
eating it,
and I feel like
every kernel I eat
is probably three times
more filling than popcorn,
so I think I'd eat less of it
for a healthy snack.
I had such good luck with
a brother and sister here
on their business
named Pipcorn,
and they have $12 million
in sales, 3,500 stores.
They would help you
with whatever you need
'cause they are about three,
four years ahead of you, okay?
But all that being said,
it's a young business.
It's not a proven model.
So, I'll make you
the $200,000 offer for 30%.
Greedy.
It's not greedy at all. I think
that's a fair‐priced offer.
That's very fair.
Savage. Savage.
Rohan, could you please
beat her up with valuation?
So, here's
the scenario.
It's a tough one because
you got the Indian side
and you got
the snacking side,
which is guiding me into
doing this deal with you.
But given the stage you're at
at the moment
and given that I don't see
the clear leap,
at least from
the American palate to this,
much as I love
the Indian side
and I love
the snacking side,
unfortunately, I am out.
Aah! Okay.
So, who's in?
Anybody here other than me?
Well, listen, I love it.
I will buy it.
But to give an offer
at this moment,
because it's lacking fiber,
I'm gonna be out.
Thank you for
your consideration.
O'Leary: I'm really
struggling with it
because I think
you're spectacular
and I got the whole
Lebanese heritage thing.
I'm Lebanese, too ‐‐
or Lebanese‐Irish.
That's close, right?
[ Chuckles ]
The trouble with this is,
your sales are tiny.
You are definitely not worth
$2 million.
I mean, normally, I would
squeeze Barbara's head
'cause she's greedy
and just do damage to her deal.
Not at all.
My gosh.
I'd love to do that
to you, Barbara.
[ Laughs ]
Find somebody else.
No, I just ‐‐
I think she's
a good partner for you.
I don't need you
as my salesman.
I'm fine on my own.
Don't mess with me,
Barbara.
I'm gonna squeeze
your head right now.
I'm fine on my own.
[ Laughs ]
Okay.
So, maybe ‐‐
You know ‐‐
Don't mess with him.
You're gonna get an offer.
Because she's
pissed me off ‐‐
You shouldn't
have said that, Barbara.
I don't care.
I'm not afraid of you.
Ooh, Barbara.
Put it in, Kevin.
Put it in.
Cuban: What are you
gonna do, Kevin?
Retribution.
Are you ready
for something wonderful?
Oh, wow!
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Barbara has made an offer
of $200,000 for 30% of Nadine's
popped water lily seed snack
company, Bohana,
but Kevin is also interested.
30% is sheer greed.
I hate greed.
Are you ready
for something wonderful?
Here's an offer.
Oh, wow!
I'll...
I'll give you the $200,000
as a loan.
Okay?
And I'll only take
8% equity.
Much less.
Ooh!
Just to mess with Barbara
because she said
bad things to me.
Oh, my God.
What a baby.
I would take Kevin's
in a heartbeat.
Now you have
a really tough decision
because you don't have
to give up so much equity.
Take it!
Don't even wait!
I will loan it to you. I'll give
it to you for three years.
I'll charge you 9% on it.
I'll take 8% equity,
go on the ride with you,
give you all my team
to push.
It's actually
a better deal.
30% is sheer greed.
I hate greed.
I can't stand that.
Thank you.
That's a very generous offer.
It is. Because nobody
would loan you money
except Mr. Wonderful.
Is that true?
No one will loan you money?
No.
Not at your stage.
Not at my stage.
Unfortunately.
Tough call for you.
Who are you
gonna go with?
I mean ‐‐
[ Exhales sharply ]
Thank you both very much
for your offers. Um ‐‐
It never sounds good when
an entrepreneur says
"Thank you very much
for your offer."
Well ‐‐ [ Laughs ]
Barbara, you should have been
much nicer to me.
You wouldn't have
this dilemma.
Oh, my gosh.
Come on, Kev.
Let her go.
Um...
So, obviously, you know,
we value our equity.
We value our equity a lot.
We think that there's
a lot of value here,
and it's gonna be huge.
Um...so...
8%, you know,
is obviously very attractive.
You're allowed
to counter.
Yeah.
There's a vast difference
between a loan and a partner.
No, I'm a partner.
A loan shark and a partner.
I help all my businesses.
That 8%'s gonna be worth a lot.
Is there any opportunity of
you two doing a deal together?
Never.
I don't even like him.
He hates that.
O'Leary:
I don't need Barbara.
I don't need anything she's got.
I'm way better than she is.
I like to like
my partners,
and then they grow
to a love affair.
That's what I accomplish
with every one.
Talk to my CEOs.
You'd be great.
Not this guy.
Okay, Nadine,
you got to decide.
Right. Um ‐‐
Um...
[ Exhales sharply ]
That's so hard.
Obviously, I would love
to work with you.
Don't you love
the dilemma?
Of course. It's an amazing
dilemma to have, but ‐‐
You're a smart lady.
What does your gut tell you?
What are you feeling?
[ Exhales sharply ]
Barbara, this is an opportunity
to really value our equity,
and, um...
so I think
I'll take Kevin's offer.
Oh!
Yes!
Looking forward
to working with you.
Thank you.
Greiner: That's what happens
in "Shark Tank."
Congrats.
Bye.
[ Squeals ]
We're so excited
to start working with Kevin.
He is a super‐smart Shark,
and he realized that, you know,
what our company needs is money,
and he also valued our equity,
and so I think that
was the right decision.
Barbara, you pissed me off,
and it cost you big.
Just because he's a baby.
He's a baby.
Don't piss off
Mr. Wonderful.
Oh, my God.
I'm so afraid of you. My gosh.
[ Laughter ]
Narrator:
Next up is a way to bring
green energy into small spaces.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks.
My name is Krystal Persaud,
and I'm from New York City.
I'm here seeking $150,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in my company called Grouphug.
So, Sharks, guess what.
I'm 31 years old,
which technically makes me
a Millennial.
But before you all judge me,
I know that Millennials can get
a bad rap these days,
but one thing this generation
really cares about
is taking care of the planet,
and a huge part of that
is ditching fossil fuels
and switching
to renewable energy.
So I thought, "I'll go out
and buy a little solar panel.
How hard could it really be?"
But the only ones I could find
were for camping, fishing,
hiking.
And if you're renting
an apartment ‐‐
like me, in New York City ‐‐
installing solar is almost
impossible to figure out.
But what if I told you
that I invented a way
to harvest solar power
from any type of home,
no rooftop and no expensive
installation required?
Are you ready for it?
We sure are.
We're ready for it.
Introducing the Grouphug
window solar charger,
a beautifully crafted,
innovative solar charger
for any‐ and everyone.
Installation takes two seconds.
All you have to do
is hang it in your window.
So, I'm gonna demo that
for you right now.
I'm facing the solar cells
outside for the fake sun.
Even Kevin can do that.
[ Chuckles ]
And while the sun hits
your solar panel during the day,
all of that energy gets stored
in an internal battery,
meaning you can charge
your favorite devices
day or night.
And the beautiful bamboo frame
is designed to blend in
with any type of home decor
so that you look good
while you're doing
a little more good
for the environment.
And, Sharks, this product
is just the beginning
of what we can do at Grouphug.
With this same model, we can
create stunning solar panels
of any shape, size, or pattern
and take larger appliances
off the grid.
I truly believe
that the future of solar
is making it as beautiful
as it is efficient,
and that's the key to getting
more people to adopt it.
So, Sharks, who wants
to join this Grouphug
and change the way
that we get energized?
Each of you guys has a sample
right in front of you
with, hopefully,
your preferred charging cable
so you can test it out
and charge up right now.
How did you come up
with the name "Grouphug"?
With the name "Grouphug" ‐‐
So, I actually have
seven years of experience
making consumer electronics.
I started off as an intern
at a tech company in New York
seven years ago.
Are you an engineer?
I'm not an engineer,
but I like to say
I'm a creative technologist.
So, I'm a little half science,
half art, is how I describe it.
Which company
did you work for?
The tech startup
was called littleBits.
Mr. Wonderful,
it's in the toy space.
Yes, I know it.
I was
an industrial design intern,
and by the time I left,
I was senior director
of product design.
I didn't want
to work for someone else.
I knew that I could come up with
something that was worth a lot.
What's your background?
So, I'm actually
a first‐generation American.
My parents are from Guyana.
My three older sisters are all
in medicine and healthcare,
so I've always been kind of
the black sheep of the family,
and it's always been a struggle
for me, actually,
with my parents that I
can actually make money
and make a living as a designer
and as a creative person.
How much charge time
do you get,
and is the intention that
this would just charge devices?
To talk geeky,
it's a 10‐watt panel.
There's a 2,200 milliamp‐hour
battery built inside,
and then that battery
will charge your phones,
tablets, bike lights.
Anything small.
Anything small,
USB‐related.
Do you have any idea
how you'll sell this?
Wait, here's
a better question.
No, that's
a very good question.
We don't need
a better question.
Wait. Have you even
sold it yet, though?
Yes. So, I officially launched
this in June, and I have ‐‐
Of this year?
Of this year.
Is this a Kickstarter
or an Indiegogo?
Yeah, it started off
as a Kickstarter.
I have $80,000
in sales so far.
Wow!
What were you
aiming for?
My target on Kickstarter
was $10,000.
Have you shipped
the 80K yet?
Not yet.
Ooh.
What does it cost?
What do you sell it for?
The MSRP is $149.
Right now, it costs me
$42 to make.
That's at 1,000 units.
How low could you get it
in quantity?
If you made 10,000,
what would it cost?
If I made 10,000, the price
would drop closer to $35.
But are you doing all of these
by hand in your home?
[ Chuckling ] No.
No, so, because I worked
in consumer electronics,
I actually know a lot
of factories out in Shenzhen.
I spent weeks there before...
Okay.
...troubleshooting
on the factory floor.
Nice. Now they're making
it for you, basically?
Yeah.
So, right now, with the factory,
we're working with them
to, like, reduce the amount
of exposed hardware,
clean up a lot of the edges,
and take it to
a fully manufactured product.
And actually, to speak
to the bigger vision,
I have a couple photos
that I want to show you.
So, this was actually
a custom cat‐shaped solar panel.
It's called Solar Cat, the
cutest solar panel ever made.
Is that you Solar Cat
or someone else Solar Cat?
My Solar Cat.
Greiner: You created,
designed it, and put it ‐‐
So, Grouphug
has a Solar Cat?
Yes.
A museum saw
what I was doing,
and they wanted to bring
something into their museum
that people could see up close
to educate them about ‐‐
That's a museum?
Yeah.
It's the New York Hall of
Science in Queens, in New York.
That's cool.
O'Leary: I mean,
in a snapshot for me,
this is
a commodity business.
This thing is gonna be
very hard to make money with.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
I appreciate it, Kevin.
I think it's really great
what you're doing.
You're so early, though,
that I just don't have
any read or feedback
on how this is gonna work
in the home
and what's going to be
people's reviews and feeling.
For right now, I'm out.
First of all, you made me
fall in love with Guyana.
Oh!
I mean, if everybody
in Guyana's like you,
I'm headed out there
next weekend.
Thank you.
Okay.
What I love is
your presentation style.
What I don't like is,
I think the product
just plain‐out
looks ugly.
And I think, most importantly,
you have a long way to go
to figure out
how you're gonna market.
I think it's gonna be
hard for you
to get
an investment on that.
Okay.
♪♪
Oza: I think your entire focus
should be on Solar Cat.
If for some reason,
on this particular product...
Yeah.
...you had special
proprietary technology...
Yeah.
...that gave you an edge
over everybody else,
I'm like,
"Let's go for it."
This thing can be replicated
in a New York minute,
and if you take
your creativity
and then start doing
$100,000 installations,
that's amazing.
But the problem is,
you haven't done that.
For me, it doesn't make sense
to back you at this stage.
Okay.
So, unfortunately,
I'm out.
So, Krystal, it's that moment
in "Shark Tank."
There's one Shark left.
I know!
One great idea
can change your life.
Now, it depends
what Mr. Cuban wants to do.
Mark, I know that I can make
more Solar Cats.
I have actually talked
to some businesses in New York
about getting them
in their windows.
What do they cost to build
something like that?
All‐in was maybe $1,000
because it was ‐‐
That's it? Okay.
Yeah, because it ‐‐
'Cause to me, there's
some corporate business there,
but out in parks
and getting a sponsor,
so if it only costs
$1,000 ‐‐
I really wanted to get one
in New York, actually.
I've been really inspired.
Right, 'cause you
want to showcase where
someone can do it, right?
So, we find a place,
put in a front
where people can sit there,
charge their batteries,
and it's brought to you
by Morgan Stanley.
Yep.
Right. So, I can see
that happening.
Look,
you're impressive.
I think there's a lot
of upside to the concept.
Obviously, the execution
needs a lot of work...
Yes.
...but I'll make you
an offer.
Okay.
I'll give you
the $150,000...
Okay.
...but I want 25%.
25%.
Um, would you be willing...
No.
...to go down to 20?
No. No.
Um, you got a deal, Mark.
[ Laughter ]
I would love
to work with you!
Greiner: Congrats.
Thank you so much!
Corcoran: That's great.
What a happy ending!
Good luck.
Persaud: Thank you so much!
Bye!
What a sweetheart.
Yeah, she's gonna be
really good.
Oh, my God!
I think I am living proof
of the American Dream.
My parents immigrated here
with $100 in their pocket
from Guyana,
and look at me now.
I just got a deal with
Mark Cuban on "Shark Tank."
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a safer way
to accomplish a common task.
♪♪
Zirkle: Hello, Sharks.
My name is Drew Zirkle,
and I'm from
Virginia Beach, Virginia.
I'm seeking $100,000 in exchange
for 14% equity in Safety Nailer.
Sharks, whether you're
picking up a hammer
or you're building a deck,
there's nothing more rewarding
than doing it yourself.
Except sometimes, starting
a nail can be challenging.
Ow!
[ Sharks groan ]
But that's why
we invented Safety Nailer.
Our patented tool
protects your fingers
while making hand‐nailing
and starting screws
easier and safer.
It straps to your fingers,
allowing for hands‐free work,
and there are strong
neodymium magnets
that hold the nail
or the screw in place,
with multiple grooves
for multiple size fasteners.
Check it out.
♪♪
It also works for screws.
Simply load it, grab your drill,
go full throttle on the drill.
[ Drill whirring ]
Hmm.
After listening
to our customers,
we invented our second model
for the really small finish
nails, screws, and staples.
Safety Nailer makes
easy work of them.
That's cool.
And lastly, these dreaded
electrical staples
that are so hard to hold.
Not anymore.
So, let's save
people's fingers
while making hand‐nailing
and starting screws
easier and safer.
Why don't y'all come up while
you're here and try it out?
Alright.
Let's do it.
Come on up here.
Safety first.
Safety first, people.
[ Laughs ]
Good look for you.
It's a good look,
right?
Click the groove.
It's angled, but okay.
So, you're gonna notice
as you drive the nail in,
it's gonna naturally
split it open.
Can you do that?
Yep.
What a man!
Voilà!
Whoa!
Ta‐da!
Was that your first nail?
That's my first nail.
Alright.
This is amazing.
That's pretty cool.
And then, this is
the smaller model
for the finish nail.
What's cool is how
it snaps together like that.
Yeah.
It stays.
It's magnetic.
Mm‐hmm. Yep.
So, how'd you come up
with this idea?
Sharks, let me tell you
the story, okay?
It wasn't invented by me.
It was invented
by my really good friend
who I went to
engineering school with.
Dan is ‐‐
Dan's an amazing inventor, guys.
I mean, better engineer,
better mind than even me.
After school,
he was enlisted in the Navy.
He became very sick
after deployment
and had to have heart surgery.
Long story short,
he was medically retired
out of the Navy.
So, fast‐forward to 2017,
and he shows me this product,
which ‐‐ let me pass around
the green one to you.
So, here's the green one.
This is the prototype?
He shows me that.
Greiner: Oh, wow.
Chiseled out of wax, huh?
Well, it was made out
of a retainer mold.
A retainer mold?
Yeah, and he used to be
a welder,
so he created
the sheet metal.
I looked at that, and the first
thing that came to my mind
was what my mom
used to tell me.
She used to always tell me,
"When you start something,
you finish it."
And I was like,
"Dan's got to finish this."
But Dan says, "I don't want
to go in business.
You know, I have good days,
I have bad days."
His wife steps up and says,
"I'll go in business
with you, Drew.
I believe in the product."
We find
an injection molding machine.
Your own?
Yeah.
Yeah, we bought one for $3,000,
and then we bought a mold,
and we made the first 2,000
by hand,
and we learned really quickly
that was challenging.
Wow.
So, where'd you go
from there?
So, what happened was,
around that time,
a third‐party company
reached out to us,
said, "Hey, let me help you."
I'm anticipating this story's
going south real fast.
You know where this
is gonna go.
No!
Long story short ‐‐
It is a long story.
But it's not short.
Wait! Stop!
We felt like
we were losing control,
so we said, "You know what?
We're gonna go find
our own factory."
So that's what we did.
China?
In China. Correct.
What do they
charge you for one?
So, we were landing for,
like, $1.75.
We sell them ‐‐ $9.99 on Amazon,
$9.99 on our website.
And what have sales
been last year,
and what will they be
this year?
$40,000 last year.
Sales to date right now
are $85,000.
I'm projecting
through the holiday,
we should hit over 100,000,
I hope.
You making any money
on that?
So, right now, we're showing
about $2,000 or $3,000 profit.
Okay. Is this
your full‐time job?
This is not
my full‐time job.
My full‐time job
is a project manager
for a large consulting firm
designing
wastewater treatment plants.
O'Leary: So, you're not
full time on this deal?
It's not bad, but it also
leaves it listless, you know?
It's sort of ‐‐
An investor like me
wants to put in $100,000
and have somebody to call
in the morning,
saying, "How's it going
with the Safety Nailer?"
I get it. I get it.
You're a great guy.
I love the story.
But I'm out.
Thank you.
You know, for me,
this lacks sex appeal.
Also, I don't think this deal
has room for any partner.
Not enough sales.
So I'm out.
Thank you very much.
Barbara, appreciate it.
The one thing
I want to bring out ‐‐
we've actually filed a utility
patent on the second product.
Drew, look, it's not even
a question of the product.
The product's great.
The challenge is,
it's not a company yet.
Whether it's you or
somebody else, there's got to be
somebody who eats, sleeps,
and lives the business
24 by 7 by 365.
You're not quite there,
where I need it to be,
so for those reasons,
I'm out.
But congratulations
'cause it's a great product.
Thank you.
Before we go any further,
can I at least show you
our other product
that's here?
Yeah, absolutely.
This is our toy product...
Cuban: Slingshots?
...that Dan invented,
okay?
[ Chuckles ]
What happened was, there was
a clacker on the floor,
and we were making
Safety Nailers,
and the magnets were in wrong,
so they flipped backwards.
Right away ‐‐ what if you had
a clacker that didn't clack
because the magnets
were always repelling?
So ‐‐
[ Laughing ] What?
What would that do?
You mean
it doesn't clack?
It doesn't clack.
And we knew.
You're probably gonna want it
to clack, I think.
Yeah, I think I do.
Well, then change everything.
I'm in.
The thing is,
kids love the magnets.
That's it?
Yeah, it's simple.
I want one.
Let me see. Let me see.
A clackless clacker?
Yeah.
What the heck does that have
to do with Safety Nailer?
I know.
Wait.
Why do you want this?
This is not just "Pitch
anything you feel like."
I wasn't trying to, sir.
This is actually
kind of cool.
What else do you got
in your bag of tricks?
There's two other products
that I can't show you guys.
No, don't show any more.
I was joking!
Okay. Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
I can't take it.
Cuban: These are
actually pretty cool.
It doesn't clack.
So, these are the only two
in the world?
Yeah.
As far as I'm aware.
Now you're down to one.
[ Laughs ]
Mark, that's gonna cost you
something, alright?
[ Laughs ]
Oza: So, Drew, look,
I love this product.
Like ‐‐ surprisingly,
I have hammered nails,
and I have hit my hand,
and when I first did this,
it was fantastic.
So I love the product.
Thank you.
This could be
a licensing deal.
And I was very close
to turning to Lori
and saying,
"We'll do the licensing."
But now
I'm looking at Lori,
and she's got this
"I don't know" look on the face,
and I'm wondering
if the clacker coming out
done messed up
the whole ‐‐
No, the clacker ‐‐
No, look ‐‐
If you guys go in,
I'll put in money just to get
rights to the clacker.
Well, to me, I feel like
this is a licensing play.
Right.
Now, Mark just said
that he'll jump in...
If I get the rights
to this.
Oza: If he gets the clacker.
...if he gets the clacker.
So, Mark,
if we give him $100,000,
you're willing to put up
1/3 of that?
Uh‐huh.
What planet
are we on here?
50/50 partners,
contingent on a licensing deal.
We will do our best
to get you a licensing deal
with a big name,
put it out there everywhere.
We'll handle the legal,
we'll broker the deal.
I appreciate your offer.
Um...
So...
33% for that offer.
We earn 66%, and you guys
are gonna earn 33%.
So, wait.
Can I take this one home?
Can I take this home?
Mark, you can take that one home
if you really want to.
Done. Deal.
Done on the clacker.
Are we done?
Yes.
How you pulled that out,
buddy, is next‐level.
[ Laughter ]
‐God bless. Thank you.
‐Thank you. Brilliant.
Cuban: Congrats, Drew.
Yes!
So, with three Sharks,
we're gonna take Safety Nailer
to the next level.
It's gonna be awesome.
You know what?
Okay, wait a second.
He is a really
good guy.
Wait a second, Lori. Lori.
The only reason that happened is
Cuban wanted to spend 100 grand
for a clacker
that doesn't clack.
Doesn't clack!
♪♪